fue una decisión que le costó el cargo a
tan solo horas de que fuera votada una
moción de censura en su contra en el
legislativo Pedro Castillo decretó el
cierre del Congreso e instauró Un
gobierno de excepción que le permitía
gobernar por decreto
convocar en el más breve plazo a
elecciones para un nuevo congreso con
facultades constituyentes para elaborar
una nueva constitución en un plazo no
mayor de nueve meses a partir de la
fecha y hasta que se instaure el nuevo
el nuevo congreso de la república se
gobernará mediante decretos ley la
decisión Fue catalogada mayoritariamente
como un golpe de estado por múltiples
sectores Y en cuestión de horas el
presidente se quedó solo la avalancha de
renuncias comenzó la primera fue la de
su canciller César Landa otros ministros
y Embajadores siguieron El ejemplo
mientras que la policía y las fuerzas
armadas se metieron un comunicado
confirmando que no acataban la orden del
presidente el congreso en vez de
atemorizarse por las palabras de inició
el voto de la moción de vacancia
ha sido dos del artículo 113 de la
constitución política del Perú
concordante con el artículo 117 de la
carta política En consecuencia se
procederá al régimen de sucesión
presidencial establecido en el artículo
115 de la constitución política del
Estado ciento uno de los 130
congresistas votaron por destituirlo por
permanente en capacidad moral solo seis
optaron por el no al conocerse la
noticia de su destitución fue detenido y
posteriormente llevado ante la fiscalía
en donde se le vio junto a su ministro
del interior mientras firmaban
documentos su vicepresidenta Dina
boluarte acudió al congreso y asumió
como nueva presidenta del país cargo que
primera vez es ostentado por una mujer
asumo el cargo de presidenta
constitucional de la República siendo
consciente de la enorme responsabilidad
que me toca y mi primera invocación como
no podía ser de otra manera es convocar
a la más amplia unidad de todas y todos
los peruanos la nueva presidenta estará
inicialmente en funciones hasta 2026
cuando abría elecciones aunque con la
incertidumbre política que atraviesa el
país desde hace años no es posible
vislumbrar si llegará al final de su
periodo